whilst they take clothes danielle has
waived her anonymity to warn others
about what happened to her when she was
just 14. what started with a child's
online game ended in violent sexual
assault there were virtual world
websites
and it was on one of these websites
that
um it all started basically so there was
private chat rooms um and it started off
as just a friendly conversation
um obviously asked how old each other
and he said he was around 16.
but the man not child john graham
edwards was actually in his late 40s he
groomed danielle in the online games
chat room arranged to meet her then
abducted her taking her to a forest he
was
very
abrupt
and
told me to take all my clothes off and i
was terrified and didn't know what to do
i didn't know where i was
and he was quite far away from home and
i just did what he told me to do later
he repeatedly sexually abused her a
digital game had led to real-life horror
and danielle's story is becoming
increasingly common data from 39 police
forces show over 5400 child sexual
offenses involving online contact were
recorded in 2016-17
but it rose 78
in four years to over 9700 offenses last
year the nspcc wants to strengthen the
draft online safety bill it does propose
criminal sanctions for companies but the
charity says they're watered down and
don't relate directly to keeping
children safe on their platforms and
they want a named person scheme which
would make senior managers at tech
companies personally liable if a senior
manager
consistently and repeatedly fails to
ensure that their platform is
fundamentally safe for children to use
then there should be the backstop of
criminal sanctions the government told
sky news our new laws will be the most
comprehensive in the world in protecting
children online failing firms will face
hefty fines or have their sights blocked
and we will have the power to make
senior managers criminally liable for
failing to protect children
danielle's abuser was imprisoned but
when released he groomed more children
and was convicted again it begins with
these websites it begins with these apps
it begins with the internet
so i think they should be held
accountable for part of this year as
this nspcc campaign conveys it's all too
easy
no idea who this is
so how can they get message me awareness
and regulation are the best defense to
protect children jason farrell sky news